marine le pen dit je le connais depuis
son plus jeune âge et on a déjà vingt
ans de complicité vous dites je connais
marine le pen depuis que j'ai 16 ans les
gens ne s'imaginent pas la femme qu'elle
est vraiment alors
qu'elle est la femme qui elle est
vraiment mais c'est une femme qui a
beaucoup de qualités et qu'on n'est pas
toujours en mesure de voir sur les
plateaux télé parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
l'agressivité des bases de ce soir on la
voit avec aso avait valu au début
d'émission avait lé journal en sextet le
courage la pugnacité ouais l'honnêteté
qui font partie à mon sens je le crois
que ces valeurs cardinales c'est la plus
grande qualité de marine le pen a pour
moi c'est l'honnêteté l'honnêteté
l'honnêteté et le grand défaut on me dit
pas et me dit pas mais elle y est elle
est trop pointilleux c'est une mauvaise
foi à mauvaise foi parfois c'est vrai ah
ouais c'est possible alors c'est quoi
souvent c'est ça son plus grand défaut
il paraît que c'est parfois de mauvaise
foi non mais elles vont trouver un
métier difficile de t'inquiéter pas le
prendre à bien non non mais bon ça peut
arriver a dit tenants de la mauvaise
mais encore une fois je vous le dit on à
face avec avec les années avec le temps
qui est passé j'ai vraiment découvert
quelqu'un d'une honnêteté qu'est tout à
fait incroyable et je crois que c'est
une qualité essentielle quand on veut
avoir des responsabilités vraiment inami
ce que la jument est clairement là là
c'est des séquences importantes pour les
téléspectateurs y joue vraiment clair
qu'on soit dans dans l'intimité c'est
vraiment une amie à vous c'est à dire
quand vous avez un souffle l autre que
voilà professionnel vous pouvez
l'appeler vous pouvez dire oui oui c'est
quelqu'un qui est très à l'écouté même
un souci de coeur ou la bolivie oui
c'est quelqu'un qui est très à l'écouté
oui c'est vrai oui vous l'avez déjà pelé
pour assouvir leur oui oui vous êtes
coach et il il lui est arrivé de me
remettre dans le droit chemin ah oui ah
bah je risque pas de l'appeler alors
mais plus sérieusement pour son bonheur
ah oui c'est vrai même sérieusement
c'est quelqu'un qui est particulièrement
écoute wiki qui conseille et j'allais
dire qu'il protège qui protège je le
vois avec avec ses proches avec son
entourage mais mais je vois aussi dans
son contact avec avec les français sur
le terrain je me souviens je me souviens
qu'elle avait été très touché par
ailleurs max et yannick jadot qui a buté
sur une éolienne
j'espère que tout va bien parce que
c'est vrai que sur un petit baky alors
il ya volonté de protéger l éclair et je
me souviens de cette de cette de cette
affection de cette émotion qu'il avait
traversé quand on est allé à la
rencontre des aidants il ya quelques il
ya quelques semaines à fréjus au ccs de
fréjus est-ce que je t'avais vu toucher
véritablement à ce moment là mais aussi
si vous voulez une fois que les caméras
sont partis on est chez moi et on en
reparle et je sens de l'émotion je sens
qu'elle était touchée par cette
situation de jean où vous le savez
qu'ils sacrifient leur vie d'enfer pour
s'occuper pour s'occuper d'un proche
malade et bon voilà il ya il sait quoi
est-ce que vous avez une vérité dans
cette femme que que
comme moi je n'ai jamais trouvé ailleurs
est ce qu est ce qu a une info que les
français ignorent et que vous pouvez me
donner sur marine le pen elle chante moi
je sais à ça je le savais je chante très
bien elle a chanté dalida
j'ai fait une petite boutique
compilation de vos prestations oh non
j'écoute très souvent dans la voiture
regardez
encore des mots toujours des mots
les mêmes mots
j'ai mis de l'ordre dans les cheveux un
ppri des noix sur mes yeux le beau temps
s'est enfui depuis longtemps déjà craint
que les feuilles mortes brûlées les feux
de bois d'abord paris si beau dans cette
fin d'automne soudain je me languis je
rêve je frissonne jeu tant que jeu ça
vire et comme à la rengaine je vais je
viens je viens je tourne et je vais
traîne ton image on monte je te parle
tout bas et j'ai le mal d'amour et j'ai
le mal de toi je vous veux dans mon
équipe
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai que vous chantez vous danser
aussi moi je vous ai vu danser vous avez
un pas exceptionnel vous avez déjà fait
la fête avec marine le pen
la vie politique c'est des moments des
moments en commun et pendant les
campagnes électorales en vue la danse
quant à la au soir de la défaite en 2009
pendant les campagnes électorales on est
on est régulièrement ensemble on vit un
peu en communauté on peut se dire ouais
et donc il nous arrive de passer déjà
fait quelques fois que cela m'arrive de
passer des bons moments qui sont
malheureusement trop tard d'ailleurs
bien sûr où on chante des oreilles vous
allez faire vous allez faire une grosse
fête en avril ah mais moi j'en suis
absolument convaincu aurait pensé que
vous allez faire une fête à l'elysée en
tout cas si on gagne c'est là où on fait
palabre est un homme peut-être mais
emmanuel macron l'invité
mais nous on pourra peut-être
vous
qu'est ce qui fait que vous a trouvé
meilleure qu'en 2002 7 en 2010 est
marine le pen
évidemment qu'il ya une expérience une
solidité
qui fait que quand on comprend en
expérience et que et que les choses sont
un petit peu différente évidemment
puisque vous êtes son ami entendu et
d'ailleurs ça se ressent le voit on le
voit sur le tout on le voit sur le
terrain le voit quotidiennement on sait
que vous êtes son ami un ami un ami un
ami ça dit j'espère jeanmairet un ami ça
dit tout ça dit les bonnes choses et les
mauvaises choses qu'est ce que voulaient
savoir qu'est ce que vous lui avait dit
oh
soir
du d'entre deux tours après le débat des
manuels matheron vous l'avez dit tu as
été bonne vous l'avez dit j'suis voilà
c'est aurait pu faire mieux vous lui
avez dit vous l'avez dit quoi dit la
vérité non mais ans au moment où moi je
sors de ce débat j'ai pas là elle a la
sensation que que nous avons fait un
mauvais départ d'accord elle ça n'est
pas je crois qu'elle a mis le doigt sur
toute une série de choses qui sont la
réalité qui se sont avérées justes
d'ailleurs sur le comportement des
manuels macron sur sa manière de faire
de la politique sur les idées qu'il a
mis en oeuvre d'ailleurs créé dans la
danse dans le courant de ce mandat tout
ça était clairement la véritable machine
maintenant qu'en effet et nous
d'ailleurs
ouais une erreur de stratégie c'est ce
que nous a dit marine le pen total on
l'a dit tout à l'heure vous la referai
pas là si vous êtes au second tour
non je vais éviter quand même a priori
vous l'avez vous l'avez vous l'avez
refaite cette soirée dans votre tête non
j'ai pas l'habitude si vous avez vous
passé j'ai pas l'habitude je je je il ya
une erreur il ya un constat
personne n'a eu besoin de me dire que ça
s'était pas passé de manière optimale un
je m'en suis rendu compte moi-même je
veux dire et puis voilà et puis
demain est un autre jour la vie commence
toujours demain et on continue tracé
alors j'ai une petite photo à vous
montrer c'est en 2009 regardez cette
avec marine le pen est
bas et ben mes cheveux les cheveux oui
ça a changé un nom pas franchement je me
demande si ce n'est pas innocent bravo
très
serré que vous étiez très très jeune en
rêver on était vrai bien sûr c'est une
nombreuse nombreuses campagnes là
c'était je crois les élections
européennes
on a vécu des choses d'ailleurs
importante sur le terrain où marianne a
fait preuve de beaucoup de beaucoup de
beaucoup de courage je pense à ce moment
je crois enfin en 2007 où elle se fait
attaqué au pistolet à grenaille où tout
le monde est évidemment un petit peu en
panique et l'ensemble des militants etc
et/ou dans ces moments là marine garde
une vidéo elle se protège mais elle
garde une un sang froid une sérénité à
toute épreuve le crétacé qui est assez
impressionnante il faut bien le dire
j'ai rixe avec ce garçon il a été
sénateur maire à 26 ans quand même c'est
fou mois 26 en jetons 3e
juste d'avis gravelines est ce que pour
finir vous avez une dernière chose à
dire les yeux dans les yeux à marine le
pen que vous buvez j'avais un truc
vraiment pendant un truc que vous avez
envie de lui dire dans le mois oui c'est
vrai que j'ai peu l'occasion de te dire
que je suis extrêmement fier de
travailler à tes côtés depuis toutes ces
années et que j'espère très honnêtement
que nous allons gagner cette
présidentielle
parce que je sais le soin que tu
prendras et la précaution que tu
prendras a bien géré ce pays et surtout
à aimer à faire attention aux français
parce que je crois qu'ils en ont
vraiment besoin
la noce
il va me la faire chialer le con way non
mais c'est vrai marie vous êtes c'est
vrai que
c'était motivant
oui oui oui je pense que quand on a du
coeur on a aussi des émotions on souffre
on rit on a de la joie cc média va être
pleinement humain que j'avais briser
l'armure hâte d'avoir soit plus qu'avant
mais oui mais parce que maintenant je
suis vieille non pas ce que vous
cherchez à faire semblant je vous dis la
vérité vous faites plus jeunes qu'avant
et pourtant on n'avait pas trouvé la
bombe on attend mieux alors c'était
quand même non mais vous lui présentez
moi je suis maire j'ai trois enfants ils
sont grands ils sont grands ils sont
maintenant des jeunes adultes tout ça ça
vous libère aussi d'un certain nombre de
choses je pense que tous les français
qu'ils nous entendent peuvent comprendre
que à 53 ans on n'est pas la même qu'à
35 que voilà on gagne en maturité on
gagne en liberté aussi peut-être
d'ailleurs